no it's 2016 you guys want to do a
jillion podcast you just fake me out I
went in for a fist bump I'm gonna
high-five and the neat does I say hug me
pretty awkward Patsy anytime you product
I know yeah hope you guys are having a
good new year so far we are this is the
first podcast other than here so that's
exciting
this table is very fun you're gonna
knock over the whole table why just do
that with your giant man oh it's on the
edge of the rug that's why it's like
halfway oh wow this is a Rockies all
right we can't have nice things trillion
this week is brought to you by Club W
have specially selected perfect for your
taste wine delivered to your door
eliminate the hassle of having a shot
for wine they do the work for you Club W
check it out at Club W calm slash Jenna
Julianne get fifty percent off your
first order that's something completely
delicious oh it's amazing our other
sponsor this week is Boyle and branch
start sleeping better with the amazing
and sweetly soft bedding from Boland
branch go to bolt in branch calm right
now to check out their selection and get
20% off your order with product code
Jenna Julian thank you to our sponsors
thanks guys it really is all icon the
edge of the rug so Colleen you want to
push it forward I mean that's kind of
risky life on the edge my better stretch
podcast table forever pushing forward
Fishburne so this week we had a few
ideas right mm-hmm um well I'll explain
the first one the first one was we were
just on a big road trip we drove up to
Oregon for the holidays and as with any
road trip you find time in the car to
you know try to kill time with games and
whatever and we were playing yeah we're
almost not allowed to play 20 questions
anywhere because it makes us hate each
other yeah we get in pretty big fights
from it
then we wanted to play like specific
2120 questions just specific to MMA and
it was like it was a lot like the
podcast we did where Jenna I like quiz
me on celebrity stuff yeah they're
called Julianne sucks at celebrity
trivia parts one and two yeah and I've
always told Julian that I'm more than
open if he ever wants to do it to me
like stuff that I'm not familiar with
yeah like that it would be funny but
yours it wouldn't be as you know the
umbrella of some sort of trivia it would
have to be like a lot of things and I
probably should know and just don't so
that you can get me back but it like I
feel like we played it for a couple
minutes and then we were like all right
we got to stop because we should do this
in a podcast we really did we said that
because this is too funny we got like
save it I know a lot about the UFC I
just like have awful terrible questions
yeah it's bad uh then so that is uh
we'll do that the second half the
podcast the first half we wanted to talk
about a Netflix series called making a
murderer a lot of you guys a lot of you
wonderful people have suggested it to us
for months and months now
Oh second that the preview is on
youtubes people started tweeting it yeah
and we've seen it in the comments here
but we finally got around to it as soon
as we got home from our trip we sat down
and binge watched the entire thing for
like what 10 hours straight yeah and
also as people requested in this comment
section of the podcast to listen to the
podcast serial which we also listen
absolutely so we finished your fire
cereal was amazing the first season so
the second season is going right now we
listened to the whole first season of
cereal which is a very interesting
unique type of podcast which we enjoyed
very much we listened to that basically
all in the car ride on the way home but
we still had some left when we got home
so we just sat in the living room and
like listened to it which was really fun
but then we got around to making a
murderer and that really was incredible
and we wanted to talk about that making
a murderer it's a 10 part series on
Netflix yeah if you haven't seen it I
don't think that there can be any
spoilers because I mean ya can't Google
what happens but we'll tell you the gist
of it but even if you watch the preview
they give you this much yeah so but if
you do want to watch it and have it be
pure then click away now because
yes um we're going to talk about it so I
mean how do we start this because it was
like it was encrypted so well done but
the story it was just a great
combination of like incredible story
that they were telling and then the way
they told it like the chronological
style which is very interesting because
it really immerses you in it yeah so for
those you know who aren't curious what
we're talking about it's like the first
part of the series takes place and has
different time-stamped footage then the
tenth part of the series so they're
filming it as time goes on and you're
watching it in that order they don't
jump back and forth so it's very
real-time it kind of makes it a lot more
like I don't like very real to you it's
just it really brings you into the
moment of each episode so you're not
feeling like you're watching a movie or
even a documentary where they wrap
everything up and keep going back it was
really just like going through time and
it's a crazy story this [ __ ] guy I'm
like at the same season a cadaver yes a
degree in minutes how walk Minnis
wisconsin' small-town Wisconsin right
remember I watched minotauk Wisconsin
it's a small town and he beat this guy
Steven Avery he gets accused of a rape
he did not commit and he gets thrown in
jail for 18 years for it he's wrongfully
accused
they Wisconsin yeah as I said that's how
a county and he go any serves 18 years
for it like that that's that's the
beginning of this so he serves that time
and eighteen years comes and suddenly
DNA evidence proves it wasn't him big
shocker
so he gets freed out of jail there's
this big thing about it as soon as he
gets out of jail him and his lawyers
like we're going to sue the [ __ ] out of
the police department of this state and
get trying to get 36 million dollars for
the 18 years of freedom they took for me
as that's going on
another thing happens which is basically
someone goes missing and it is tied to
him they had the police pin it on him
the way that is done though is the
craziest part of all serious like I
don't want to say anything fact like
factually because a lot of it's still
just like at least according to the
police department is still just like
word of mouth or who said this allegedly
you know that but basically the the way
that series paints it out is that this
woman who went missing did have business
with Steven Avery she worked for auto
trader he had a car lot and they weren't
they you know they had business together
and as soon as they found that
connection when they were searching for
the suspect of the missing person they
took him away from his house the car lot
the entire Avery lot on Avery Road and
they quarantined his place for eight
days and the police just occupied it for
eight days like eight whole entire day
and nights police 24 hours a day on the
property doing what they did like no one
really knows what they did except for
them sure enough they found evidence
with a key fingerprints all this stuff
and they put it back in jail for the
murder of this woman yeah this series is
incredibly popular so many people are
watching right now as they should be
because it's just a really crazy story
and what really well-done but we like
it's just such a roller coaster of
emotions like if frustrates you so much
well I think that the the point of the
story is to show how the cops have now
two times at least been involved in
doing something that they shouldn't be
doing regardless of whether or not like
we know he didn't do the rape in the
beginning but we don't know a hundred
percent if he committed this murder or
not but they're definitely like police
Follies all over the place and like
really it's just like an eye-opening
look at our judicial system and how many
flaws it has like for him to get out of
jail the first time took them forever
and ever and ever you know to go through
the appeals process and all that [ __ ]
because our system is kind of [ __ ] up
like once you get thrown in jail for a
crime it's almost impossible to get you
out of there you know even if given all
the service
against you like this situation so I
think that people might be forgetting
that yeah it's a Netflix show yeah it's
all [ __ ] up but they didn't exactly do
the best job of pointing out that there
is another side to this
yes very ones that maybe he's not
innocent
maybe he did commit the second crime
people in the comments section of that
the trailer on YouTube are like nah dude
I [ __ ] live here he killed that girl
like blah blah blah and my first
reaction to the entire thing as I was
yelling and screaming in the living room
as we're watching it because I have been
a juror on a murder trial in the past
when I was about 19 years old in
Rochester New York and I was an
alternate I was the second-to-last
person to be picked yeah and even if you
know the the cops framed him for two
crimes he didn't do and you know lawyers
were doing their jobs the best that they
can to the best of their abilities both
in defending him and also trying to put
him in jail the jury made some serious
mistakes in finding him guilty two times
the first time is completely ridiculous
to find him guilty of rape absolutely
insane no jury should be able to find
him guilty
that's a rape kit it's like okay it was
him right second of all and in the
second crime there is just way too much
reasonable doubt it's absolutely insane
and what I think was so important about
the entire series as a whole is to show
you that they had a difficult time that
second time around finding jury members
that were not being you know completely
exposed to Steven Avery as a person all
of his you know get to being thrown in
jail then coming out of jail and then it
was hard to find impartial church yes
especially since the the police and all
of them were were really hell-bent that
they want to disguise because what you
mentioned earlier is that he was suing
Manitowoc County and the Sheriff's
Department and all those people for 36
million dollars and their insurance
policies had you know deemed it so they
weren't covered for what they did
that they maliciously threw a person in
jail and that they were all personally
being held responsible there are 36
million dollars which is why they have a
lot of motive to do something bad but I
just could not get over the fact that
this is such a painting of what happens
when we hold people guilty in the court
of public opinion when people jump to
conclusions that they know like the
people in the comment section on YouTube
we know he [ __ ] did it like you don't
live here you don't understand we
followed the news as it happened but
like if that happens in your
neighborhood likes you I feel the same
way everybody feels that same way oh my
god I already know this story I know
that guy he's [ __ ] terrible when in
reality nobody knew a lot of the the
facts of the crime until they are
presented in court
no one knew them and these jurors that
were on that [ __ ] trial have just
done a terrible injustice two times now
in Manitowoc County although the other
one was in Calmette next town over or
whatever by being by going in biased and
being selected for a jury while having
these predisposed ideas and opinions
about who Steven Avery was which is
horrible because that's that's like the
the last check and balance that we have
in order to make sure that this doesn't
happen and people have to be like all
the cops like oh the [ __ ] judicial
system Oh like when in reality there's
12 people being held responsible so that
this doesn't happen it was it was it the
juror the jury part was very very
frustrating to watch for me too because
did you find him guilty well yeah and
like it you you only heard from one of
the jurors and he was the excuse juror
he had a family emergency couldn't he
couldn't be on the final jury so he had
to be excused but he was in that he was
in the room for the entire trial and as
soon as they went to deliberate he had
to go and you heard from him and he was
like they you know he could speak on the
fact that there were like a lot of
stubborn people on that jury there were
people who had their opinions and
weren't moving right and most of those
people were the reason that they took a
couple days and then they ended up
flipping and whatever he said they
pulled the jury and at first most people
were in favor of not finding him guilty
that there were three or three people
who weren't
really stubborn people yeah but I'm
sorry then then you don't [ __ ] visit
and it's a visitor whatever yeah not and
that's fine I you know the thing about
this whole thing is that it really just
kind of seems like the perfect storm the
way everything went down it was it was
this guy had a bet you know and I'm I'm
still like I don't know for a fact what
happened obviously but the guy had a bad
rep right the police department clearly
didn't like him estate didn't like him
the jury clearly was made up of people
at least a few of them who had opinions
about him which is dangerous [ __ ]
especially on a trial this big and then
you go to the part where the state and
the police department have so much power
in in a sense that they control the
facts the news and the way the news got
out like CBC was like at the hand of
that guy cats and all these people on
work the work yeah but he got he got his
so yeah - oh we're gone you don't like
the way the new like for someone if I'm
just like yeah I grew up in Manitowoc
and like this guys [ __ ] guilty [ __ ]
him i watch the news like yes maybe you
have that feeling maybe you did watch
the news live maybe you did live down
the street from him but you have to
understand that the police department
was feeding the news when it suited that
like the news popped up in different
stories and different parts of the story
came out to the public when it was
convenient for the state side of the
case and that no matter what came out of
the case what factual evidence appeared
or was submitted in evidence in the case
or in the trial the the defense
attorneys couldn't do that they had no
power to just go to the news and be like
hey talk about this like you know to me
in the States and the judge [ __ ] them
they weren't allowed to
you know multi-point to any sort of
third party responsibility times
yeah they deny which is getting [ __ ]
sidelined the entire time as a purpose
which is all disgusting it's all the way
that it all happened the way that
everything went down is disgusting but
what bothers me the most is that I feel
like jury duty in our culture in America
I don't know how it is in your country
for listening from another country it's
almost a joke that people are like oh
man I gotta go to jury duty and they
I've sat in that room before when they
pick jurors
everyone is just like oh I can't I can't
do it I have to work you know what I
wants to do it I've heard people make up
the most ridiculous things like I'm yeah
I'm blatantly racist I can't be honest
yeah I've you know my sisters brothers
uncles see American [ __ ] lazy right
was was the victim of a violent crime I
don't think I can be fair and impartial
and there were very few people when I
got picked to be on a murder trial that
were in there that were willing to be in
there everybody else we had somewhere
else to be and they just couldn't
stomach the idea of wasting their time
and that's what I really feel like if
you're in a small County like that
chances are you have to just pick people
that would rather be somewhere else
they would rather just deliberate and
come to a decision and get it over with
I don't want to be in this jury room for
more than four days thinking about this
murder let's just [ __ ] find him
guilty because everyone wants us to get
out of here
but that's so terrible and awful that we
as people and citizens don't take our
civic duty seriously when in reality you
have power if you're a juror someday
which I hope that you are think it's an
important experience you have the power
to you know really affect someone else's
entire life yeah and and like you know
here's the thing like now it seems like
increasingly so that people are lazy and
they're finding ways to get a de jure
jury duty so they can go home whatever
like the law I feel like hasn't really
caught up with that so it's like in a
situation like this when it's so
overwhelming that all these jurors are
so influenced and they so have opinions
that they would be like okay we're going
to wait a week go gather a couple other
jurors from the next state over who know
nothing about this and we're going to
put them on trial you know what I mean
like something like that where you think
okay here's a problem with these jurors
who are not going to give a fair trial
let's solve that problem I'm not saying
that's a solution I'm just saying like
in in this story there never really was
a chance for a fair jury to happen
because they are they were picking from
a pool of really shitty [ __ ] people
being jersey
in every high-profile case it happens
like Michael Jackson OJ Simpson people
have takes a long time to find a jury or
even Robert Durst in the jinx yeah
time to find people that have not been
exposed to the level you know just media
garbage that could sway them in one
direction or another and it's and people
equally are not honest about their
predisposed opinions and thoughts in a
way that's helpful to pick a jury yeah
um it's just it's a huge failure in to
service across the board that this can
happen to someone and you know we all
feel relatively powerless about it but I
hated as a person that's had that
experience I hated that that you know
the whole show kind of glazed over they
were like oh the jury deliberated and
then they just found him guilty I'm like
wait [ __ ] how somebody get those
[ __ ] in a room and have them
explain themselves how dare you you know
yeah it was incredibly fresh and all of
those [ __ ] cops should be in
jail I don't understand how they never
got in trouble or held accountable for
what they did I can understand how you
know Steven Avery settled his lawsuit
and didn't get 36 million dollars but
how come no one ever created a criminal
case for those people on the sheriff's
whatever I mean and it's so frustrating
because they're like you're like a third
of the way through the entire series and
you see how all of these sheriff's and
all these people in the police around
are being deposed for all the [ __ ] they
[ __ ] did all the illegal all the you
know horrible vindictive [ __ ] they did
to get Steven Avery in jail for 18 years
and you're like oh [ __ ] like they're all
getting to pose they're all getting
caught in their tracks they're all
getting caught in their lives this is
going to be good like we'll see
something happen of some sort of justice
but then as soon as you start to get
somewhere they find this ugh this out
where they're like oh [ __ ] look he
murdered someone let's just [ __ ]
forget this and so then they literally
repeat that behavior and never again in
the series do you feel like they ever
get any sort of you know punishment or
even question about the way they like
and that I that's obviously the most
infuriating part as you as you watch it
it's like the police are just doing
whatever the [ __ ] they want they're
doing whatever the [ __ ]
they're having come that's the saddest
part about our judicial system is that
this happens all the time that police
pick and choose who they don't like it
happens often and oh please yeah of
course with the cops know everybody it's
really [ __ ] awful and even in big
cities that they act they know who all
of the people in their town or city or
area that they've deemed a problem and
they just like [ __ ] with them their
entire lives it happens all the time I
mean this is a you know a high-profile
case and now everybody's got it in there
you know the forefront of their mind
because of this series but I don't know
it was kind of one-sided and it also I
feel like was just like placing all the
blame on the cops when in reality
there's a lot of blame in a lot of
different ways in a lot of areas yeah I
mean the senior guy obviously he just
wasn't a saint the way he was man as a
belay obviously you know it was kind of
a shitty guy sometimes but um you know
the whole the whole [ __ ] like there
was didn't it never felt like there was
a single rule that the police had to
follow like the eight-day search
completely stupid completely over
excessive just unreal that they got to
occupy the property for eight days and
then you know in trial when they're like
you [ __ ] planted this evidence
they're like how dare you accuse awesome
planting evidence
we are respected as tea and they're like
that's how you answer that's how you'd
answer a [ __ ] guilty like kidding me
you're not like he clearly has you for
this like you're on [ __ ] eight days you
joking when are you allowed to occupy a
place for eight days just because you
want to I don't know and then the whole
the whole interrogation of the nephew
sorry then
yeah the nephew was insane wasn't saying
because the kid was you know he was very
very unintelligent and they put him in a
room and they literally cracked him to
the point where they like with their
tricky you know techniques because all
these cops who interrogate people they
know techniques they know this [ __ ] they
studied it and they trained for it and
they overused their power on this kid
who has like a shred of an IQ and that
they make him commit to you know um you
know I admit to this thing you did
induced what was the name
I didn't do the West Texas 3 or whatever
they are
oh yeah the Lost Boys of Tech or
something I came up you guys know what
I'm talking about if we talk to him talk
to us I don't know but it's on HBO it's
very good ok it's a three-part series
and it was sort of the same thing as the
nephew lower IQ kids all experienced
were coerced and they sat in jail for
[ __ ] 20 years and then finally got
West Memphis Three West Memphis sorry
sorry yeah the same thing but they they
recently got out I mean within the last
5 10 years they've gotten out you'd
think that the nephew would have an
easier time getting a better or
different new trial because of that
completely coerced confession but you
know towards the end of the show they
show you know they're not giving him a
new [ __ ] trial and it's impossible
it's just in here and convicted guilty
it is so [ __ ] hard to get you in our
fighting completely upstream like almost
impossible they make it almost
impossible that's not justice they just
want to [ __ ] they want a decision all
right you're guilty done we're not gonna
talk about it ever again you know yeah I
know none of that ever felt like they
were trying to get justice that's the
problem with our judicial system is that
it's really even about justice yeah yeah
yeah but that's just why I wish people
you know was outraged and upset as
people are on the internet and
everything they did they just love to
forget how sometimes our own thoughts
and actions contribute to sad things
happening like this yeah yeah because
you know all the people commenting you
know how dare these cops how data could
they you know they they could have been
the person who hated Steve Avery for
five years growing up and then got
called on to the trial and was like no I
don't know who that is and then [ __ ]
convicted him like that could be that
person you you thinking with this
mentality like it can never be me but
then you also hold these opinions that
you think are harmless they might not be
harmless someday well yeah and also if
you're if you're [ __ ] pissed off at
something like this
if you don't like it next time you get
called for jury duty go sit in that
courtroom and say yes I can be fair and
impartial in this trial as long as
that's the truth don't try and get out
of it don't try to make excuses your
world can wait it's an important
experience to have and it's it should be
very difficult to find someone guilty
like that's the the burden of proof they
have to prove to you that there's not a
shred of any other possibility that
could have happened in order to find
someone guilty and people to beyond
reasonable doubt me you hear it all the
time that people are getting convicted
guilty of things that you're like but
how how can you how is there no
reasonable doubt I don't understand
there was plenty of reasonable doubt in
both of his cases in my opinion you know
that you bring it up a kind of a point I
want to make um you know I've talked
about this before but growing up in
school and and this is me in I grew up
in California I never felt like there
was 1 2 3 or any real classes I took
that helped me in in real life kind of
[ __ ] there wasn't like an accounting
finance class basic finance class that I
took there wasn't a lot of real life
things that you you could easily have
taken in a class and other countries
often do take certain classes that help
you and another one would have been how
to be a juror or what it's like to be a
juror because now like at least for me
it's like I know obviously you had class
where you learn about US history or you
know checks and balances you learn all
the facts of how the government works
that you never take a class of like you
know being a juror right and you know
you take that class and you're like ok
puts you through this this this class
this course this discussion where you
really are conveyed to that being a
juror is more than yourself it's way
more than your your weekend plans or
whatever the [ __ ] you might be doing
when you get a call like it's just
bigger than you and I feel like a lot of
people never have had that realization
they never know that and so when they
get called they're like oh [ __ ] it's
your duty just like you know everyone
all my friends says jury duty sucks like
[ __ ] it let's get out of here and you
were talking about how you got asked you
know can you be fair and impartial I
didn't get that far I was I dressed up
our classes don't like a jacket and I
sat there all day and I was a glasses
but I dressed up as well and I went to
jury duty and I spent like like 9 a.m.
to like 4 or 5 p.m. there just sat
around waited and they called my name
and they said sorry you're dismissed see
you next year and I'm like ah I mean
yeah it's I get to go home but I was I
was like committed to this you know I
wanted to I wanted to do this if I had
the opportunity and like it bugs me that
a lot of people are just so quick to
want to get get out of it well I mean
think about it like this think about
when you go to the DMV I like to use the
reference of you know the DMV is like a
slice of life like there's literally
every one in there and so whenever you
like make a joke you're like oh it's
[ __ ] it's like the [ __ ] DMV in
here there's people from all walks of
life in there now imagine you take every
person that you see in the DMV at any
given moment you put them all in a room
and they need to make a life-or-death
decision together you don't know each
other and you can't talk to each other
about the trial until the trial is over
you're sitting in a room together from
all different backgrounds nothing you
guys yeah you guys need to decide
together even though you know half the
people that were sitting up there might
have fallen asleep at some point zoned
out don't [ __ ] care they'd rather be
somewhere else they're not listening
they're not [ __ ] paying attention and
you guys need to sit together after it
because mine was like two weeks so after
the end of two weeks now you guys all
finally have a chance to sit down and
[ __ ] talk to each other about the
trial imagine trying to come to a
decision with people like that it's very
difficult and it takes people that want
to do it in order to do it effectively
unfortunately it's just impossible to
find a jury of people that are like that
all the time because you know if you
find three jurors
that are really stubborn in one way or
another the other amount of people and
they're just sitting there like yeah I
mean I guess you're right all right
that's the problem for some people yeah
is that for every one person that has
thoughts and ideas or really cares about
what's going on there's ten other
[ __ ] passive people in the room that
are willing to let you just make the
decision I mean I don't know I don't
know about you guys but being in that
room and
and like having this discussion about
our real I mean that sounds [ __ ]
interesting to me I want to do that I
want like that that sounds like
something I'd like to do in my lifetime
yeah I don't think we ever in school had
like a mock trial yeah we didn't like
him in effect no yeah we did like a mock
like um like debate we did debates like
like [ __ ] we did mock presidential
debates but I mean we didn't even
[ __ ] do mock jury trials I mean at
least I can't remember maybe we did but
obviously didn't work because I'm not
remembering everything I mean that was
my only two cents that the shower
document area whatever didn't address it
all jury is that there there is some
blame to be just on the people yeah that
were able to find him guilty yeah
because the police can hate somebody and
frame them for crimes all they want you
are the last line of defense to make
sure that this doesn't happen yeah and
if if you're too [ __ ] lazy or don't
care don't turn around and then care
about it when Netflix comes out with a
documentary of it well I think that's
part of the good at this document it's
gonna kind of like at least hopefully it
opens the people's eyes to why this
happens and the fact that you're sitting
here on your couch watching it but you
are directly correlated to this like how
you were part of this man yeah and and
don't ever go into a trial with a
predisposed idea because of what the
news tells you have a [ __ ] sense of
skepticism we also remember that the
news the news I mean as much as you want
to believe what they say it's fact they
are tough they you know their business
yeah I'm trying to make a buck for
themselves so when they when they break
news when they make news stories they do
in a way that's gonna get them ratings
disgusting it's just the way it works I
know it is good as discussed I mean I'll
tell you one thing sitting down and
watching that was great but at the end
of it I really needed to get myself a
glass of wine and you know be great is
if it was delivered to my door that's
what club w can do for you guys sign up
for club W what happens is you fill out
this survey okay they ask you a couple
questions they're different tastes you
like different tastes you don't like
they form a selection one in my leg so
they send you your wine you taste it you
fill out a response very simple very
easy couple of questions they take that
response and they move forward in
selecting specifically tailored wines
for you and then
next shipment of wine that you get
delivered to your door without moving
off your butt is even more specific to
your taste and then by the end of it you
should be finding wines that are perfect
for you not for your friends who say
this is good wine not for your mom who's
like get this wine no it's the wine that
you like because your taste buds said so
so I am about you guys I even said this
in a vlog yo day I buy wine by how cool
the bottle looks and that's a very very
final batch for George it's it's not a
high success rate method because because
I'm looking at the party bottle so check
it out Club W I really think this is a
great like way to get your wine go to
club w.com slash Jenna Julianne and
you'll get 50% off your first order so
give that a shot if you guys like wine
obviously only if you're a legal
drinking age if you're not and you can
find a way to do it with your parents
and then steal it
I'm just kidding I don't do it unless
you're an attorney unless you're
obviously unless you're 21 and then you
know when the wine bottle is emptying
you got to go to bed you want to get a
great night's sleep
so check out Bolin branch for the most
comfortable bedding I've ever touched or
heard of or experienced Bolin branch has
all your bedding needs sheets blankets
all the stuff and we sleep on it
currently and we hold true that it is
some of the most yeah I'm not going back
you can't you absolutely can not use can
it's like so comfortable full and branch
and you get 20% off your order guys with
product Oh Jenna Julian at Poland branch
go to bowl and branch that's bol L and
branch calm and check out their
selection they have a lot of stuff and
just know that it's not a it first of
all it's delivered to your door you know
if they go shopping for which is nice
and it's not a big mask company that has
factories and shitty paid workers they
take care of their own and a big portion
of your purchase doesn't just go to them
they donate to a lot of different good
causes so check them out thank you to
our sponsors thank you guys alright what
do you say we get a little light now
alright yeah we need to get light up and
he's good lit
let's get lit I saw a tweet that I was
laughing at
retweeted it was like to all the thick
girls out there they don't feel
confident I just want you to know that
you should love your body girl because
you can't spell cellulite without you'll
it I left way too hard at it
yeah like [ __ ] yeah dude alright so
we're going to do 20 questions MMA style
because this is basically gonna be my
version of Jenna doesn't know [ __ ] about
this so I'm sorry if this goes a little
slow for those of you listening no it'll
be fine if you guys aren't you know you
busy
and you don't want to deal with us being
you know goofy and [ __ ] bye Felicia
oh by the way have you guys ever seen um
you haven't seen Straight Outta Compton
right no okay if you guys have seen
Straight Outta Compton can you just
agree with me really quick that that
whole scene when that dudes girlfriend
Felicia goes into their hotel room when
they're partying they made that whole
scene so Ice Cube could say bye Felicia
I mean right like come on yeah I haven't
seen it but that's not ask if it's his
son who's actually but the scene ends
with a bye Felicia and you're like wait
did they just make that Mull entire
scene so you could say that yes yeah
okay here's what we're gonna do I'm
gonna have the person that I'm going to
be picking and you have to ask but I'm
gonna say it into the Mike so you gotta
cover your ears when I say it so they
know the whole time you'll guess I'll
take my headphones take your headphones
off and plug your ears
make sure you can't hear me I'll whisper
we're good we're good alright bye
Felicia
go ahead okay do I know this person you
know who they are are you sure you know
who this person is yes okay um is it a
guy
it's a guy hey um alright Z is retired
he's not retired okay Z he's still
fighting yes busy does he have a belt
mm-hm I'm sure he's a lot about he
doesn't have a championship belt oh it
has ever is ever fought over a belt like
in a title fight yes he's fought over
about okay even if it's only two
brothers are fighting over
okay uh Z is a little guy little guy see
a big guy this is the hardest part of
this whole game she asked like four
sizes she says just little and big he's
big I see the biggest nice not the
biggest guy
okay so ah it's not big country Nelson
no that's the biggest I see it was step
below the biggest yes so Blake Anderson
Silva sighs no he's a step below the
biggest okay so Anderson zomo is
Anderson some of the biggest know what
wait so what's it what's the step below
200 205 205 is Anderson his father - if
I but that's not his primary class okay
so he's two elephants to her okay I knew
it huh okay see uh see Hispanic no is he
Samoan I don't know he's not some home
is he a Caucasian white male no no no
okay is he african-american yes is the
African I don't think he's African okay
just checking
I don't know he could be a friend is it
John Jones yeah it is yeah that was done
relatively painless he should have just
learned my first guess it took me way
too long to get to John you too long um
alright you got another one yeah and
they take all right we're good alright
okay should I go yeah to the car it just
makes me giggle - okay okay
is it a is the guy you know no okay
Ezio Z low guy mm he's a little guys
burger
is it a zero tired Zia the t mighty is
it Demetrius Johnson
- mine is it Demetrius Johnson's wife Oh
destinies onsen ya know - mighty no I
said it's a guy okay it's nobody on t
mighty okay dammit [ __ ] okay um so he's
he still fights still friends Susan are
tired no I just think it's terrifying zu
does he ever - yeah it is amazing that
does he have cauliflower ear yeah ooh
it's a Frankie Edgar
no what no it's actually good yes no it
is no it's not freaky no it's not
Frankie Eiger
okay um see like a tea wrestler what
what are you asking is he is he good at
wrestling yeah but he's not primarily
arrests okay so Xia is does he do do
Jitsu no that's not his primary
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu um see a kickboxer
he's striker striker hmm see ya busy
Caucasian yeah okay good one but he's
not he's only Caucasian like he's from
the caucasus islands like his skin is
white oh yeah just one just askin is he
married is he married yet I don't think
he's mad does he want to be I don't know
I'll ask him - I don't think I don't
think you want Syria is his favorite
book Treasure Island okay um Oh see ya
wait is he a little guys here we already
accepted there we go Isaiah mmm there's
a light guy yes he uh he is this is
counter McGregor yeah alright now we're
getting more painful I was good though
it makes you laugh
Ellen drop your armor but dammit alright
okay what how am i doing that's pretty
good
definitely better than the car oh yeah I
had the giggles yeah I said this game
gives me the keys okay is it a is it a
girl no ma it's okay little guy
yeah does he identify as a guy uh yeah
he does
so you see he's in a safe space okay um
hey Zia feel a little guy no a big mo
but he's not a little bit bigger is it
Lieutenant Dan no no I don't know I
figured it somewhere in between there's
someone that didn't have legs so okay
okay so he's not a little guys I bet
yeah it's do just a regular guy yeah
okay cezzah does a regular guy away like
174 175 no what 170 170 170 r all right
dizzy uh does he love America uh I don't
know
no clue okay yeah
does he look big back tattoo like is
this whole back covered in a tattoo
no his whole back is not covered in its
whole front cover no it's not what about
his calves no as calves are not tattooed
does he have like yellow feet you asked
this but what the [ __ ] is that suppose
you know what they're like rolling
around in your like what was his foot
look so yellow no that's like what
happens when they touch the canvas
that's not their feet color hmm okay so
he's a regular guy does he have a belt
yeah oh is it Robbie long yeah
yeah nice job he's asking about did his
face split open
yeah that would have been him too good
go ahead that'd be good what do you why
you smile it's just funny you're funny
you're funny you're funny
yeah somebody else yeah okay cuz uh do
we know in strategy if you play twenty
questions and you're trying to get to if
you know somebody little personally no
do we know him yes then it it like
answers gender and yep we don't know
hair alive like everything okay all
right that is a guy yeah okay Ziya
disabled belt no mmm does he like belts
I think you probably like it's okay mmm
okay is it a clay guida he says yeah
yes wait what yeah he's like my favorite
pocket fire is he's hysterical are you
serious oh you just got it I thought I
was getting it as a joke to me picking
out a joke
oh we double joke to each other's good I
can't believe the only time I guess is
it Clay Guida is the time when it
actually was actually angry that mm
kissed it [ __ ] psychic okay do more
yeah he still makes me laugh my media's
psychic psychic sisters hire me psychic
twins what is that is that a new channel
I've heard all about that [ __ ] yeah
Shane keeps talking about them Shane
jams oh okay is it a guy it's a guy is
he uh the little guy sometimes
what yeah as long as he does he like to
be a little guy who does he want to be a
big guy okay primarily who is it uh is
he blond No
okay izia wait so he's middle to little
yes there you go
Mills a little guy this is that way
class called hmm m'little is it
this is eyk yeah he's like a Zia brown
hair yeah
Zee bald though he has he's brown hair
is he retired no hmm Dominick Cruz this
is a Kenny Florian no mmm is it Kenny
flourines wife it's definitely nothing
to do with Kenny Florian is he um hmm uh
disease to the it both of his arms is he
married no no [ __ ] way no way ah is
he tall
yeah I'd see like over six feet tall oh
I think so this is Stefan Struve I said
little guy to middle o-73 weighs like
300 pounds oh so he's a little middle
guy middle middle but he's like six feet
tall it's pre talking so he's like a
good green bean yeah fair enough
hmm real tall brown hey sir Rory
MacDonald no hmm doing a hint no okay um
does he ever it like to take deep
breaths and then break people's arms in
half so it's sir no it's not Frank
mirrors what you're saying yeah okay but
yeah he does that too is it okay give me
a hint
okay we've driven through his hometown
mmm I don't know what was your hint does
he live in Sacramento no good yes sir
does he live in Long Beach huh does he
live in um Oregon no hmm I remember we
were in the car and I said we are
driving through blank this is where
blank trains and lives
is it ng yes yes is it Nate Diaz yeah he
drove through low tire Stockton oh
that's right let's say oh yeah this is
fun are we still playing yeah you were
doing my yeah
[ __ ] you should I do
let's do rock up no what the hell and
done I hear listen no I didn't I was
just I thought you were like drinking
Jack here but it's been a long time
thinking [ __ ] da you why you just
leaving down life for so long brawl
that's what that's what he said dude
both the [ __ ] bear that's your special
it's your area yes do that to you is it
a guy what that's for like what was that
it's a fine oh damn Breen is it a guy uh
yeah no no no it's a girl yeah it's girl
uh okay does she find it 115 know it's
Friday 135 yeah who is it veg go he'll
love this guy oh my god the Internet's
real special is sign the best guy all
right I got this is it Rhonda no is it
Mischa
no is it a girl Rilla no is it Liz
Carmouche
no that's a third person okay is it Gina
Carano no is it cat Zingano Gina Carano
fire 145 times I was like come on let's
go
no it's not kind of thing up is it uh
Chris cyborg
who kiss you love Chris okay
is it 135 dude what the [ __ ] why am i
running out of people and it's a girl
mm-hmm then she fought is a holly hall
yeah
oh come on being funny a face Jenna I
will do another one that was too easy
that was tweeze II I was tweeze II I was
tweeze e Michael Bisping yeah I did it
mmm you're excited all right is it a guy
or is it a coil mmm
it's a guy what if you were a guy all
names Kyle Kyle named Niall oh I win I
win they're ahead um is he a babe as you
see a total babe no do you do you chair
you milk with him I was here my mother
Lynn but I wouldn't like he's not
talking okay um Lizzy big guy hmm
you see an average guy is average big
okay izia see a white guy yeah
there's yeah was a brunette see ya is he
a brute is he a brown hair yes Goodman
hey I think his brother hmm actually no
no he doesn't matter is he retired
Google a picture really yeah is he
retired uh he's not retired does he have
a belt no does he want a belt
yeah he's brought her yes he wants about
it does he fight for belts yeah what is
it Carlos Condit no he's fighting soon
hmm okay is it does evil hmm
to zfo mmm see the word tattooed on his
body he has no tattoos no his tattoos I
don't think is a werden hmm you know it
might be a word but you've never seen
that data okay does he have so he has
tattoos yeah does he have any like are
you like mmm let me let me search my
database have fighters attack okay all
right
dizzy yet hmm
does he have a beard no hmm
guess who all right does your guy wear
glasses no okay
which is a middle sized guy yeah yes has
he ever fought ideas no is it Nick Diaz
no he's not
father yeah that's a great guess cuz
Nick can't fight himself oh my god he's
not my ideas okay so is he bigger than
the Diaz yes he's a middle sized guy so
is it Chris Weidman middle sized middle
size Chris Weidman no okay is he the
same size as Chris I need a little size
I know but it's not saying that you see
the first name again middle same it say
middle are you doing it just a little
little okay what are you doing okay
alright never mind how does a technique
it failed go
has he ever fought Chris Weidman no so
is he bigger than Chris Weidman yes okay
um he's a white guy
guys why okay he's got brown hair yeah
he's a big guy it's a middle guy don't
like yeah you see the the middle wait
yes that's Roberta yeah there's still
kind of big if you think about it it's
middle way but it's so done big I said
kind of big do middleweights way like a
like 191 185 middle okay middle okay
mmm-hmm I'm trying to think of who has
that belt right now he doesn't have the
best no I'm trying to have someone that
does that
okay so he's bigger than Chris what
Chris Weidman who is it ah wait a minute
wait a minute doc me sorry [ __ ] he's the
same weight class as Chris Weidman damn
it I'm sorry
oh you don't [ __ ] down has he ever
fought Chris Weidman I don't think he
has not is it Vitor Belfort no is it nog
is it little no no he's in his Jubba
um mmm Goodland how much anyway again is
he um who disease does he have really
done does he pretend to head no does he
does he shave his head he has dizzy
little wifey yeah
he's awake does he have babies yeah hmm
mm okay
mm-hmm I know the name it was kid yeah
won't help Callum Callum yeah hmm not
dalam right caliber sighs I said go
his kidneys are gone is their daughter
Christina and our son Colin I'm gonna go
check okay uh see it is easily a happy
face see look isn't really a happy
looking no no you look say another happy
[ __ ] face is he like an angry guy
yeah
Missy of like it's daddy issues and
stuff I don't know about that no no does
he hate everybody
aa little bit mmm but he's a white guy
he's a middle guy he's not retired but
he's never fought Chris Weidman I don't
think he's [ __ ] Swiper no
is it Robbie Lawler no he's he's we
already covered he's about to yeah okay
oh so he's bigger is the American is the
American to that face the American no
he's not an Australian no is he uh
British hmm who's a Bisbing hmm I hate
him for no real reason
yes I have no reason to hate me but I
just do you ever just he's a way happy
face his face is super happy I'm happy
at how much he trolls everything would
have got it like ten minutes ago if he
said yeah it's face to superhead okay uh
visiting the fact that you hate him
makes him so happy that's what he wants
see ones behind I don't really I'm not
busy I don't I've like I know you can be
kind of like you know an antagonistic
[ __ ] sometimes but I like him I like his
schtick and I was like him as a person
I actually met him he did yeah I was in
college and our baseball team was
supposed to work security for the street
fair and he was at Street Fair because
he wasn't Orange County hmm and he
walked up and I was like hey I'm working
but can I get a picture and I have a
picture with him and the picture is of
me at like 160 pounds well Jesus is tiny
but I was like so excited to meet him
you were your middle
I was lighter than him you were like he
was probably like 200 pounds either
middle okay middle okay
this podcast is brought to you by the
letter middle the letter middle yeah is
that our cue that is that do we need to
get you some Club W yeah yeah yeah okay
Benson Bolan brain ah thank you -
bowling brain best most comfortable
sheets in the world check them out guys
seriously you will have great nights if
you will wake up not wanting to get out
of bed and I won't blame me because we
do that to bull and branch comm products
code Jenna Julian 20% off your order
Thank You Bolin branch and Club W guys I
forgot to mention Club W grows their own
grapes and for those who don't know what
grapes make wine and they make their own
grapes to make their one yeah [ __ ]
crazy right absolutely
yeah check it out Club W have wine
delivered to your door specified for
your palate it is amazing club w.com
slash Jenna Julianne 5050 50 percent off
your order on use that URL or just click
in the description we have all the links
of all our sponsors always in the
description let's check it out what is
this like this American Life let's do
this American Life voices what oh no
today on this American Life
we have poem bridge welcome to cereal
China is gonna make cereal what kind of
cereal
the first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna grab my cereal and I'm gonna get
my almond milk now the almonds
you say are these organic like stolen
from with my money
okay this is gonna end right now you
guys whole podcast just like yeah you
guys want to be infuriated for 45
minutes we'll do podcast like that
thank you all for watching and listening
to our podcast you guys are the real MVP
we appreciate you guys here's to an
amazing 2016 for a great podcasts and
weird things like that yeah yeah she did
she good alright see you guys next week